trying to find the right actors for a
film can be pretty difficult from the
lead role to an extra in the background
every decision is pivotal to a film
success in the following cases the
casting decisions were so terrible that
it left a lasting impression on us all
and not the one they were hoping for
unfortunately for these actors they were
caught in the crossfire of playing
characters they just weren't right for
Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor one of the
all-time great comic book villains Lex
Luthor is right up there with magneto
and Doctor Doom so when news broke that
Jesse Eisenberg would play Superman's
arch enemy in Zack Snyder's Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice let's just say
that fans weren't exactly pleased things
only got worse once people actually saw
the film while DC fans and movie critics
usually don't see eye to eye almost
everyone agreed that Eisenberg was
totally missed cast as the Man of
Steel's main villain many believed that
his interpretation of the character was
far too manic way too loud and too
similar to a certain Clown Prince of
Crime little retinol big bang you let
your family die well there's no denying
Eisenberg is a brilliant actor here's
hoping as Lex Luthor stays locked up for
a long time Scarlett Johansson is major
one of the biggest casting scandals in
recent history started in 2015 when the
world learned that Scarlett Johansson
was cast as major in a live-action
remake of the 1999 film ghost in the
shell' the original is generally
regarded as one of the greatest animes
of all time one problem major is
Japanese Johansson is not the news of
her casting sparks fury not only by
people who saw this as racially
insensitive but by people who wanted an
authentic film over 100,000 people
signed a petition in protest advocacy
groups condemned the news and soon
hashtag white washed-out was trending on
Twitter the film ended up bombing at the
box office and some suspect that the
critical backlash surrounding the
whitewashing incident was the reason for
it hopefully the Scarlett Johansson
controversy will convince Hollywood to
be a little more diverse when it comes
to casting although it will probably
just inspire Studios to stop remaking
anime movies altogether Mark Wahlberg is
Elliot more by and large M night
Shyamalan has a pretty solid track
record when it comes to caffeine but as
far as
casting mistakes go it doesn't get much
worse than Mark Wahlberg in the
happening put Wahlberg in the right film
you get movie gold but shove him into
the wrong movie and you'll send your
audience into the wrong kind of
hysterics
and in this eco thriller Wahlberg is
definitely in the wrong role playing a
panicked high school science teacher
with some of the worst line delivery in
cinematic history plan on murdering me
in my sleep what no in all fairness
Shyamalan script isn't doing wahlberg
any favours but the actor does bring an
extra special awfulness to the film even
wahlberg himself admitted the film
wasn't his best work saying that it was
a bad movie still we kind of sympathize
with the guy he probably just wanted to
try something different
the second you were children in a second
okay why should anybody give me a
goddamn second Robert De Niro as the
creature the legendary Robert De Niro
experienced a rare flop with his
performance as the creature in Mary
Shelley's Frankenstein sure he might
have been less ridiculous if he had less
ridiculous makeup but the problems
didn't in there his portrayal was also
panned for maintaining a modern New York
accent in mid-1700s geneva the fact that
he was still the same you talking to me
De Niro that we all know and love was
distracting at best and absolutely
terrible at worst Kevin Spacey is Bobby
Darin
when singer Bobby Darin died at 37 his
legacy left a big impact on the music
world among his dedicated fans was Kevin
Spacey who spent more than a decade
trying to make beyond the sea a biopic
about Darrin's life most studios were
reluctant to finance the film because
Spacey wanted to produce direct and play
the lead even though he was
significantly older than Darin Spacey
stuck to his guns and eventually got the
deal done with Lionsgate many thought
that he did a great job performing Darin
songs but that there was something weird
about watching a man in his mid-40s play
a character in his late teens you don't
care about people heard you don't give a
damn about
New York Magazine wrote that Spacey was
too jolly for the role adding that it
felt downright pervy to watch his love
scenes with Kate Bosworth so while
you've got to give Spacey points for
dedication casting someone who was in
two decades too old for the part would
have been a better move Jennifer
Lawrence is joy Mangano
everybody knows Hollywood has a major
problem when it comes to casting women
over 30 that means a lot of younger
actresses get parts that are probably
better suited for ladies with a bit more
life experience if you need proof look
no further than David O Russell's
casting of Jennifer Lawrence enjoy this
fact-based 2015 film focused on joy
Mangano a 34 year old single bomb who
overcame life's obstacles by creating a
self-wringing mop and finding success as
a TV personality as the movie centers on
a woman in her mid-30s it might have
worked better if the role had gone to
someone in that same age bracket even
Lawrence confessed she was too young for
the role but she justified it by saying
Russell doesn't worry about silly
questions like age that sounds nice when
you're getting high-profile parts but
older actresses might not think those
questions are quite so silly Sophia
Coppola in The Godfather Part 3 when
Francis Ford Coppola made the decision
to put his daughter Sophia in the role
of Mary Corleone in the third Godfather
film the results were disastrous whereas
the first two films in the Godfather
trilogy were exceptionally good part
three was a mess her stiffness on screen
was palpable especially in the moments
when she shared the screen with her more
established co-stars
[Applause]
dad
Mickey Rooney as mr. Yunioshi file this
one under never again Mickey Rooney's
cartoonish portrayal of mr. Yunioshi and
Breakfast at Tiffany's is basically
unwatchable Rooney was widely respected
thanks to the rest of his immense body
of work but the image of him wandering
around with taped eyelids and large
false teeth is hard to unsee so much so
that the film which is otherwise revered
for Audrey Hepburn's iconic lead
performance has been consistently hit
with backlash for its cultural
stereotyping mr. Gore rightfully okay
all day thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]